hello everybody welcome to the last
session of pi data we have Henry choir
he's in University of Bremen working
with Institute of information management
and he's going to talk about data
science for digital humanities so please
give him a round of applause
thank you very much I hope can you hear
me yeah thank you for the introduction
and thank you for sticking with me and
coming here I'm going to talk about data
science today's humanities but also a
bit about computational social science I
use these terms somewhat interchangeably
as already said I'm with the University
of Bremen during my PhD there studied in
Stockholm and Helsinki I have a website
if you want to find out more but let's
start with a nice example I don't know
who a few has seen this example of
target so this is the u.s. shop and they
did figure out that the woman was
pregnant before she realized it herself
so they basically look at her buying
other buying history and analyzed that
and then I try to send her targeted ads
so they give her coupons for the family
and in this case she didn't know she was
pregnant but she was already getting ads
for pregnant women and that was huge
that was a huge outrage for the family
but you can also think about the
consequences in a culture where teen
pregnancy might just not be okay because
woman is not married and you don't want
to be the one who's outed by Target or
is outed by Erika that you're pregnant
to your parents you probably want to
tell them yourself and I like this
example because it just shows that
really simple data can give away a lot
of really important patterns another
thing and you've probably seen this arm
is sentiment analysis this has huge
commercial appeal because if you're
Amazon and you want to automatically
decide whether people do like a camera
or they don't like a camera then it's
really really helpful for you to have
sentences and be able to say whether
they're positive or negative
and the way this connects to digital
humanities and while I'm bringing this
up is that you can of course also do it
on political debates so here the company
from Sweden called gavagai who's
providing an API was mining a lot of
data that published on Sweden in
newspapers in blogs on Twitter and then
they're basically aggregating how the
people in Sweden feel about refugees so
this allows really exciting research on
a large scale because you can basically
look at every tweet you can look at
everything and then analyze it it's also
reductionistic so we have to use it
sensibly
in the abstract to this talk I promise
that analyzing millions of images and
enormous text sources using machine
learning it's simple and straightforward
in the Pisan ecosystem and I hope I can
convince you there was a lot of talk on
machine learning here I usually love to
bring up this picture because that's
kind of the essence right you have two
classes and you wanted to basically
classify them and you're just trying to
draw this line between the two classes
so that's the essence of machine
learning is basically the cover of one
of the nice machine learning books and
you probably heard this the data science
is just statistics on a knack but I do
like the definition that a data
scientist someone who's bad at
statistics than any software engineer
and that our software engineering than
any statistician and that's the
definition I'm going with just a quick
of course overview in academic world
there's already a publication 2001
likely slant on data science and he
basically saw it as an enlargement of
statistics and the important thing about
data science is this learning from data
and you've probably also seen it called
the sexiest job of the 21st century but
I want to show how this is relevant and
how this is useful for scientists in the
social sciences in the humanities and
really famous example is this by Adamek
and glance who famously visualized the
divide in the political blogosphere of
the 2004 US election and for that they
compared 40 blocks over for over two
months and they visualized who is
linking to whom and they kind of showed
that conservative blogs they tend to
link to conservative blogs and liberal
blogs tend to link to liberal blogs and
there's not really much exchange between
the two of them and the nice thing is
really that it's one of these things
that everybody kind of had a feeling
that this was happening you know you
probably heard about the echo chamber
you probably heard about filter bubbles
but this is super obvious and very very
nicely visualized and makes this problem
very very clear I really like this
notion that computer science or Internet
Explorer in German is just mathematics
plus X so there's not really much
computer science in itself it's always
in relation to something it's always
applied to something it can be applied
to biology it can be applied to various
business cases and that makes computer
science and informatics fundamentally
postmodern at the same time
computational is this nice new paradigm
and of course this goes nicely with this
increase in volume variety and velocity
of data what we usually call big data
and I like to give this to my students
as a thought experiment because many
people here probably are really good at
coding in that they're good at
explicitly formulating instructions
working with loops working with
conditions but if you were tasked with
writing and explicit program for that it
would be very very hard there's really
hard to tell what makes a six or six
gets really philosophical but of course
you can just learn it from data you can
just inferred from the data and for me
doing data science always a bit like
playing Lego because we have these nice
tools we have natural language
processing toolkit we have word two Veck
and Spacey
we have visualization tools we have
topic modeling tools I'm going to talk
in a bit more detail about topic
modeling because that allows really
really exciting research in the
humanities and then of course I could
learn was mentioned many many times
Kara's tensorflow Theano
cafe so this is a really nice overview
and you're basically just stacking
together it's really like playing legal
in the abstract there was also this
example that you should imagine a
journalist who wants to cross-reference
the names on the guest list of a
parliament with online information about
lobbyists and then the goal was to
identify which party in this Parliament
would meet which company and this is
actually from the keynote of PyCon
Sweden 2014 I like it very very much and
in this example Helena banks son who at
that time worked at swaiiow television
which is the Swedish IRD who's now at
the Guardian she looked at the lobbying
in the Swedish parliament and to really
just naively ask the people in the
parliament basically people at the front
test if she could get the list of
visitors and they gave it to her and
this is actually the list so you see who
was visiting and you can also see who
they're visiting but you don't know who
they're lobbying for it's just their
first names so she made this very very
simple program which is really she has
nice hacker attitude and she just
combined it in a very nice way [ __ ]
which basically took this excel list of
visitors of the Swedish parliament and
she expected the names of the visitors
and then she found the lobbying agency
the visitors working for and at the same
time she got a kid list of Swedish
companies and she found the lobbying
agency that was employed by the company
and it's really like a funny situation
because on the one hand these lobbying
agencies are very very proud of the
people they employ because they went to
good schools and they're somewhat famous
at the same time it's really important
for them to show they're working for
famous people they're references so the
task here was to find them and this is
really just simple data is great
a pretty sure that everybody could do
this here but using that and then
looking at the intersection set of these
two data sources she could expose
lobbying now the sweets are nice people
but they're not stupid so at some point
they decided maybe it's not good to give
them the entire list of visitors to the
Swedish parliament they made it a bit
harder and they basically said you have
to come there and you can do one request
to a day by mail in a letter and then we
reply in written form to make it really
make her life a bit harder but thanks to
machine learning thanks to the Pisan
ecosystem and her hacking skills she
then basically added optical character
recognition of this printed list of the
visitors of the swedish parliament and
NL script could use could could work
again another nice example which kind of
shows the power of using computational
methods in this humanities and social
science context are these small world
experiments and it goes back to this
idea there is about looking at the
average path length for social network
of people and you probably heard about
some of you have heard about this idea
of six degrees of separation and it
means that all living things and beings
and everything else in the world is just
six or fewer steps away from each other
so that a chain of a friend of a friend
can be made to connect anybody basically
saying my professor knows politicians in
dream they know politicians in balloon
and that's basically my path to angular
miacca
and that's how well I know her and this
has been studied in 1929 already there's
also a famous study by Milgram of the
Milgram experiment of some of you know
but where it got really interesting to
us in this particular case is when
Duncan what in 2001 at the time he was a
professor at Columbia University
attempted to recreate this experiment he
basically had an email message that was
the package
and he sent that to 48,000 senders in 19
different targets and he found that the
average do not next one so they were
longer paths the average number of
intermediaries on this path was actually
six so you could show that on a large
scale with 50,000 messages that people
are actually that well connected then in
2007 there was another study by Google
is assessed and a recall of it and they
examined a data set of instant messages
that was composed of 30 billion
conversations with 240 million people
and they again found that the average
path link and in this particular case it
was on Microsoft message where messenger
was six again so as you can see it shows
two things it's research that has been
done but you can now do it may be
simpler but also at a much larger scale
you can have millions of people billions
of conversations and you can easily
crawl them so who of you actually had
heard the term digital humanities before
I actually am yeah I'm surprised
so the humanities are the academic
discipline that studies the expressions
of the human mind
we call it geysers and shuffle in German
and digital humanities is then meant as
the intersection of the humanities as we
know them and computer science because
this opens up new research methods and
it creates a new environment in which we
can try out new things and it's really
interesting on one hand we have this
unprecedented amount of data that's born
digital
you know like Facebook messages and they
just they always have been digital and
on the other hand we're digitizing a lot
of stuff you know if you look at Google
Books a lot of these books are available
and the hope is of course that this can
help us enhance our understanding of
individuals and collectives one of the
first times this was done it's quite
surprising
in 1948 so these scientific
collaborations between computer science
and the humanities then again nothing
new and there was a Jesuit and
theologian called Hobart Boozer and he
did approach Thomas J Watson who was the
founder or the founder of IBM and he
wanted help to index the work of Thomas
send a query for Thomas Aquinas so they
basically did this index domesticus
which is considered to be the first
electronic text project in the
humanities and it's a really significant
earlier employment of computer resources
in the humanities one thing that's
really really nice and very very helpful
is this so-called topic modeling and I
know there was a talk and a tutorial on
that but just a quick repetition to get
everybody on the same page so there's a
technique called latent directly
allocation and the idea is to represent
documents as mixtures of topics so
basically say every document is a
probability distribution or has a
probability distribution of having a
certain topic or talking about the topic
so each document problem is a
probability distribution over topics and
each topic is a probability distribution
over words and you can see that here so
you have the words like gene DNA and
genetic and if you have enough data even
an unsupervised fashion you kind of see
that they have something to do with each
other they call cure they're close to
each other and if you do that for many
many topics in an iterative fashion you
get very very different words that
represent the topic and you can then
also show which document is associated
with which topic and to make this much
more much more visible I have this very
very small toy example for latent
dirichlet allocation and we just pretend
we have these five sentences and the
first one would be I ate a banana and
before breakfast the third-born for
instance concealers and kittens are cute
and the first one look at this cute
hands the munching on a piece of
broccoli and you probably all would
agree that there are two main topics in
these sentences one like one topic would
be food and the other one would be cute
animals so this is basically this
probability distribution over the corpus
so we can see okay they're like words
that are somewhat connected because they
talk about the same things and they
occur in some sentences so you can say
okay the first two sentences are about
food the third and fourth about good
animals and this is really interesting
and that makes so powerful the said the
last sentence is mostly or much more
about food and somewhat about animals
because it has munching and broccoli
that makes it more about food and we all
can also then say okay topic a consists
of the words broccoli bananas breakfast
and munching but we can also say of how
much it basically consists of these
topics and the same for topic beam and
this was then used to analyze journalism
so there's a paper called massive scale
automated analysis of news content and
what they did is they took this huge
corpus with two and a half million
articles from about 500 English language
news outlets so it's basically
everything in New York Times has ever
published everything voyageurs is
publishing and they use this late into
early education to annotate it into five
15 different topic areas and then they
compared the news outlets and the topics
in regards to the readability which you
can measure the subjectivity and gender
imbalances so linguistic subjectivity
for in so for readability there are many
scores and you can find you can just
basically look for readability scores
and you find them and definitely 70s but
they basically tell you okay somebody
has to be at this school grade to
understand this text
Macklin linguistic subjectivity for that
they basically looked at the adjectives
and the amount of adjectives and the
sentences then they had a dictionary
where they wrote down sentence happy is
a very positive word said is a very
negative word and then I combined that
and here then I applied it to a variety
of newspapers so in the simplest case it
just looked at these 15 topics that they
derive from the data and then they using
a mathematical method projected down
these this information to make similar
newspapers being close to each other and
what you clearly can see is that there's
a cluster of quality newspapers and it's
the Wall Street Journal being completely
different from anybody else because
probably is only talking about politics
and you have a lot of other newspapers
you can then also look at how these
newspapers do compare in terms of
readability are they easy to read are
they hard to read and this linguistic
subjectivity which is based on
adjectives and how we basically assign
their happiness the valency and you can
see that these tabloids like the Sun and
the Daily Mirror they're very very
easily readable and they're pretty
subjective they have a lot of adjectives
The Wall Street Journal again being not
so readable but also not being quite as
unreadable as something like The
Guardian but the least subjective and
you can also do it for topics so you can
say that articles about business and
politics they're very hard to read and
they're also not that subjective whereas
something about fashion has a lot of
adjectives which of course makes sense
or something like sports is very easily
readable and you cannot only do that for
newspapers of course you can apply that
to any kind of text source so this is
another example called macro analysis by
researchers from North America which
basically
use these digital methods for literary
history so Jacques is the one who wrote
the book and he showed that factors such
as the gender of the author the
nationality but also the date of
publication for novel does affect the
choice of literary themes in novels so
for this they use these topics from the
topic modeling and they're not perfect
right exist the probabilistic model to
look at similarities as well I quote
avec so you try to learn in an
unsupervised fashion from the data so it
can't be poor can't be perfect but you
gives you some insight and they cleaned
it up and then they identified and
expected hundreds of topics from a
corpus of 3346 works of the 19th century
British Irish and American fiction and
these are entire books so three thousand
three hundred books it's really hard to
read that many books let alone annotate
them for their topics but again using
bethe science using this kind of methods
they could conduct this analysis so here
are examples for the topic so for
instance on the bottom right you see
this big cluster connected to education
so knowledge is really big education
pupils study learning or the one on the
top right connected to family and mostly
nieces and nephews so the visit of the
word cloud also takes the word count
into account so it's really exciting and
makes life a lot easier but on the other
hand is of course not perfect and this
is a picture of the gizzy protests where
they basically did an analysis on
Twitter on the usage of the hashtag
connected to gazing and if you look at
this you see that you if you look at the
data at the third of tune the usage of
the hashtag drops drastically right less
and less people are using this this
hashtag and one might conclude that the
protests died down around that time but
what they did
and it's actually wrong citation I'm
sorry about that but the online
ethnography revealed the opposite the
protest did not did not die down the
protest became this story the dominant
story so everybody who was tweeting
about the gezi protests that's what that
was all they were talking about so they
just didn't need the hashtag but just
from looking at the data just from
taking this quantitative perspective you
would have never guessed this and it
kind of motivates that it's important to
combine quantitative methods like these
with qualitative methods that is talking
to people because what they did is they
basically reached out to these twitter
users and asked them you know what
happened did it die down on the third
another problem connected to big data
and the like is the famous example of
the Google Flu Trends so the flu kills
half a million people a year so it's a
really good idea as you say okay we can
predict whether the flu will hit a town
where whether there will be a flu
epidemic in Berlin just by looking at
search engine query data and these
people published in Nature which is
super famous right that's where
basically Watson and Crick published
about the structure of DNA and they said
okay we can predict this the problem is
they couldn't because after two or three
years there was this issue discussed and
science of big data hybrid Hyper's
because this model about Google flu
predicted more than double the
proportion of doctoral visits then that
then actually happened and there were
two main reasons the reasons for that so
there's this big data hybrids and the
algorithmic dynamics so algorithmic
dynamics means that the Google search
engine is always changing so engineers
are doing changes every day to improve
it as a commercial service but this did
basically create feedback loops and led
to huge overfitting in the algorithm
so now one other thing I would like to
talk quickly about computer vision and
how that can be used in a context of
digital humanities and computational
social science and who of you has seen
these image net competitions who have
you has heard about that okay so almost
half the idea is basically to find
objects and images and you do that with
a thousand categories and this is really
diverse it goes from leopard to cherry
to container chip and what makes this
special is that you have 1.2 million
images for training and you can reuse
these networks so it takes a like a lot
of time to train them and you need a
bunch of GPUs for that but you can
basically fine-tune that you can do this
kind of transfer learning and there were
some talks talking about this already to
basically use them for your purposes I'm
just click skipping that one but if you
have this network that is basically
trained on image net and it's trained on
predicting these thousands of categories
you have vectors representing the image
right you have something and you put
something through your neural network
and at the end of it you basically have
this one layer the one before the neural
network makes the decision what class it
will predict and this is usually on
sometimes a 4096 dimensional vector
that's a representation of what's in the
image and you can then use that to
position different images on this map
and you see that similar objects end up
being close to each other and end up
being next to each other and this
dynamic you can basically hack and you
can use for your own research in one in
the simplest case you can even have very
very few images for instance of cats and
dogs and then use these features to make
the decision whether this is a cat or
whether this is a dog but what you can
also do
is to apply this to paintings right if
you would train the same like like a
similar network on paintings you would
be able to find similar paintings and
find paintings that show similar things
very very easily and again you could do
this with millions of paintings without
usually any computation computational
power and time and what's interesting is
that you've probably all seen this by
now
so these semantic relations in words of
X you know there's one dimension
representing rural and there's another
one that could be named as like the
gender like the femaleness this also
holds true for generative models in
terms of meaning that you can basically
take a picture and then apply a vector
and make this person smile so this
probability distribution that's
capturing a pace and you add a vector
and make somebody smile or you turn
somebody in a female version we turn
somebody an old version and but you can
basically do that because it's a
generative model that captures something
about faces and then you basically take
a picture of me when I'm young of me
when I'm not smiling and when I'm
smiling and you take that vector and you
apply it and this is really really
exciting because it will make these
things olaf was talking about possible
and even more powerful so this is an
example from berkeley where they
basically have you sketch something
simple you just draw a line here you
draw a line there and a draw low down
there and then the neural network is
kind of sampling from this probability
distribution that it learned on millions
and millions of images and it will
generate nice mountains with just like
very very little user input because it
learns to represent structure in some
cases learns to represent what a face is
on this case it learns what kind of
images you gave it so if you want to get
into this I have three recommendations
for books the Cathy O'Neil Rachel shut
book is very nice was one of the first
books on data science mostly conceptual
gives you a very nice overview about
designing data science because everybody
is talking about it but it's relatively
new and we as a community don't really
have a good idea what is data science
and what's not so I really like that as
a start if you want to get into the
programming aspects it's really good
introduction to cycle learn and in
practice but also machine learning in
theory was written by one of the
creators of scikit-learn
and then a bit more PhD level at the
book on deep learning by the NGO Coover
and good fellow I think is the best book
on deep learning and it's surprisingly
readable it even goes through the
mathematics and I think you can still
look at it for free online before you
buy it and with that I'm happy to take a
question thank you again
[Applause]
are there any questions
can you comment a little bit on the
slide that you had skipped oh okay yeah
sure now that we have the time to talk
about brain right yeah so this is from a
TED talk by yoshua bengio and it's about
neural networks and it's but it's
basically meant to give you a nice
intuition of how it works because if you
apply this to images on the lowest level
it learns filters which are maybe like a
horizontal line filter or a vertical
line so this is like mostly edge
detection and on the next layer of this
neural network it's recombining these
filters right because it gets these
neurons as input and combining them
getting a bit more zoomit geometrical
shapes and it's going up and up a bit
skeptical about this actually capturing
meaning I think it's really good at
capturing probability distributions for
sure but what's exciting is that these
lower filters they correspond to the
brain so this is right among cognitive
scientists but this does correspond to
what we know about the brain and there
is like experiments where they did
really weird things to the brains of
cats to put stuff in there to see that
we actually have these kind of surface
and hi so you're in like the area of
digital humanities and you say that
you're kind of more on the computational
social science side and but like one
thing I was wondering is just because
you're on the edge of sort of like two
disciplines like computer science and
then so that social science do you ever
find any like pushback between the two
disciplines and like when you want to
publish do you find it difficult to kind
of select venues or do you find there's
more venues appearing for this
intersectional sort of research that's
happening yeah thank you for the
question
the funny thing is actually at my
research topic my PhD is in
human-computer interaction and what
trust in machine learning and this
emerged from this we've been building
tools for geographers for sociologists
to visualize things or even machine
learning at the time but just to
visualize this and ended again this
looks cool but but and then there's a
long pause you know because they don't
really know how to use it for themselves
but they also not really sure what they
see so really want to help them to
understand these kind of things and so
I'm much more oriented at these
traditional Valley venues but there's
more and more coming there's a digital
manatees conference it's also a
wonderful summer school in Oxford which
is a bit pricey but so I first heard
about digital manatees when I was
studying in Helsinki and the professor
went to the summer school and he
recommended it it's very nice
thanks for the presentation quite an
obvious question but why do you think
that it has taken so long for
programming and more statistical more
hard skills to penetrate some humanities
cool and I know that probably if we take
in northern European humanity school
you're going to tell me that they've got
actually the best stats teachers and the
best Python teachers but I come from
southern Europe and there there's kind
of this very clear divide between soft
skills go to one side hard skills go to
another and they never quite meet I
think it's always individuals who have
been doing it and they have been doing
it forever like this monk who wanted to
study these texts right I think now it
kind of become popular and more
mainstream and I think a lot of people
like the majority of people in these
social science departments actually see
the benefit now I think there were
always pioneers who understood it and
who wanted to do this everywhere in
southern Europe as well as in northern
Europe when you are showing the layers
right of abstraction connecting within
Andrew energies you know lectures and so
on
now we have the classification of the
images right and influence of similar
images do you know of any things that
like will quote any attempts to classify
the four-dimensional events with a time
dimension so like let's say a video that
in which certain things happen like
maybe parts of the movies in the movie
maybe some you know actor goes and falls
down the cliff and that's one of the
events right yeah but when you think
about I mean so now I'm like because I
was fiddling with it
I know I have plenty of fret
thank you friends in multimedia and
there is a conference called ACM
multimedia and they have these Alice TM
- this basically mixture of lsdm and
CNN's where you can actually do this
kind of analysis and figure out in
videos what actions are taking place in
this kind of research so there's really
active and a lot of advancement in the
last year's in that I see do you know of
or have you ever heard of intelligence
advisors which would basically collect
information that you would say with
cameras that your experience over your
life and recommend you know or predict
what kind of things are going to happen
in you know what you should do you know
I have another
I can give that back to the audience
maybe somebody who knows can come back
to you and with that gives up the stage
thank you very much
[Applause]